We have 3.7 million farmers
and more than 10 million fish farms all across Indonesia.
My dream was to operate
my own fish farms,
a thousand fish farms.
I tried to speak to many
farmers back then,
and I saw similar problems that the farmers face in feed costs.
And from that discussion, impulsively, it’s just a
spontaneous idea that
I pitched to a farmer, hey,
what if I can build a machine
that you can feed your
fish from your phone?
And they were very
excited about it.
My name is Gibran Huzaifah.
I'm CEO and
co-founder of eFishery.
Our approach is really
how we can help small-scale
and smallholder farmers
increase their productivity
and provide efficiency
on their biggest cost,
which is feeding.
It’s 70 to 90% of the total cost
and currently done
manually by labor.
They're managing 20 farms
and they have to feed
the fish by themselves.
It was really a hard job to do.
So that's why we started on
building this eFishery feeder.
So this is a machine to
feed the fish automatically.
It is connected to the cloud
and connected to the sensor
that can sense the fish’s appetite.
So it can improve
the feed efficiency or the
feed conversion ratio
as well as increasing
the growth of the fish,
so they can shorten
the harvest cycle.
We already have 75,000 farmers,
farmers cooperatives
and farmers groups.
And in total we have close to
250,000 funds all
across Indonesia.
And we are already 27
provinces all across Indonesia
and in 350 cities.
I saw entrepreneurship as a tool
to really change the
livelihood of families.
And building the business is not
about creating your
wealth for your own,
but really building a community,
building the impact for
a bigger sector to more people.
So I think that's my first
tip for the entrepreneur.
I think if you would like to be a tech founder, really ask yourself
whether this is what you
really want to build and why.
Find your why, find your reason.
And the reason it's not really
about being cool and being rich.
It needs to be a bigger reason than that that you would like to
aspire to be.
So for me personally, I
measure my own success on
that impact level.
Because I want to see
myself at the end of my life
to contribute to solve
world's hunger problem.